sie ist präzise die uhr
die die ewigkeit anzeigt und man hört
sie nur wenn man das ticken ihres
uhrwerks misst der uhrenmacher roman
weniger hat sich weniger hat in
zusammenarbeit mit einem kanadischen
künstler eine uhr gebaut die normal
aussieht aber alles andere als normal
tickt der zeiger auf 12 uhr gestellt
dort ganze 1000 jahre bis er eine
umgebung schaffen kann
[Musik]
den ruhm
es geht vor allem darum sich in
erinnerung früher für sich nicht mehr
vergönnt ein uhrenmacher der die genaue
zeit relativiert das gibt es nicht oft
vor allem wenn er dann doch eine präzise
uhr bauen wie ganz mechanismus eine
versucht so einfach gestaltet wie
möglich dass man da einfach satt gibt es
rat gibt wo die einem jahr ein streit in
zwei jahren ist reiki 100 jahre
einigkeit und zeigten sich auch einige
weniger hat die zeit verlangsamt indem
er auf ein klassisches uhrwerk mehrere
zahnräder zusätzlich ein boot
sie teilen die zeit neu und etwas anders
sein
es geht nicht mehr um minuten oder gar
sekunden
das ist dass das rad wo einmal im jahr
tritt einmal die zwei jahre einmal in
hundert jahren
das rad dreht einmal in hundert jahren
ja da kommt dann noch ein paar teile
dazu natürlich aber eigentlich ist das
ganze ist um ein modul integriert und
wurde noch so werkhof ots da eine uhr
keine uhr ist wenn das verstreichen der
zeit nicht bemerkbar ist hat weniger ein
guckloch eingebaut
hier können wir sterblichen 10 in
welchem monat in welchem jahr und in
welchem jahrhundert wir uns befinden
dürfen wohl die sich jahrelang und
fahren sie weiter gibt und wie man sie
konserviert wo sie oft apathisch und so
öfter wird noch gefragt sehr viel auf
die eu tue sich ja und das ist natürlich
klar nur weil auf nicht ununterbrochen
sich also das nicht möglich und ist
jetzt mit der technik nicht möglich
wie jede mechanische uhr muss auch diese
getragen werden damit sie läuft und
irgendwann muss man sie ihre medien
war es also wieder hunderte arten
ausgeht dass man als partei liegend
wolfgang jäger in den verschachtelten
felsen haben und dann sagen die leute
sind denn der satz teile
übrigens steht die uhr auf 5 nach
dann sind circa 80 jahre vergangen ein
durchschnittliches menschen lieben